on fait comme je le fais évoluer
l'arsenal législatif pour qu'il y ait
des interdictions judiciaires de stade
et que ces abrutis n'est plus de place
dans nos
inintes normalement la cellule signas
sport ne prend pas en charge les
signalements en lien avec des actes
d'homophobie ou de racisme donc le fait
de ne pas clarifier en fait ce que
j'essaie de de de dire c'est soit la la
la cellule signal sport ne prend en
charge que les VSS et dans ce cas-là
faut clairement les dicter et donc faut
indiquer y compris aux associations
qu'elle qu'elle ne signale pas à Signal
sport mais qu'elle passe par d'autres
instances pour que les affaires soient
traitées soit on décide d'élargir le
périmètre de la cellule et dans ce
cas-là on indique à tout le monde qu'il
faut qu'elle signale sur signal sport
mais l'entre deux manque de clarté en
réalité parce que si les associations
peuvent saisir mais qu'en réalité c'est
pas tout à fait le cas ça enfin moi je
trouve que du coup ça crée beaucoup de
confusion
j'assume que la priorité de signal sport
soit la lutte contre les violences
pourquoi parce que nos ennemis sont qui
là
l'omerta la
passivité la complaisance nous devons
donc mener des enquêtes avec toute la
diligence la fermeté
nécessaire quel est le sujet sur les
discriminations quel est le sujet c'est
que justement quand il y a des gestes
antisémites en tribune quand il y a des
cris de singe tout le monde l'entend
mais personne n'agit en aval le sujet
c'est pas de révéler ces faits le sujet
c'est de les traiter c'est de les
éradiquer donc on saisit la justice on
saisit les commissions disciplinaires on
fait comme je le fais évoluer l'arsenal
législatif pour qu'il y ait des
interdictions judiciaires de stade et
que ces abrutis n'ai plus de place dans
nos
inintes le sujet il est fondamentalement
différent
fondamentalement alors moi je fais en
sorte oui quand il y a une victime qui
est perdue
elle soit pas laissée complètement sur
le bord de la route et donc je vais pas
dire que ça va être zéro traitement
parce que c'est pas le bon canal non on
prend en charge on remet dans les
circuits idouine le reste c'est
l'application s'agissant des luttes
contre les discriminations c'est
l'application des protocoles qui ont été
prévus c'est l'application des
interdictions judiciaires de stade c'est
la mise en œuvre des interdictions
administratives de stade c'est la mise
en œuvre des interdics commerciale de
stade c'est les réunions avec les
associations de supporters c'est les
réunions les ateliers de sensibilisation
avec les associations qui prennent en
charge les victimes c'est la désignation
partout de référents sur ces sujets là